dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here this is
our 200th episode so I know you're
expecting something great see how you
like this one one of the most
sought-after effects in light transport
simulations is capturing indirect
illumination this is a beautiful effect
where the color of multiple diffuse mat
surfaces bleed onto each other and of
course computing such an effect is as
costly as it is beautiful because it
requires following the path of millions
and millions of light rays this usually
means several hours of waiting time
there have been countless research
papers written on how to do this in real
time but the limitations were often much
too crippling for practical use but this
time around you will see soon that these
results are just outstanding and we will
have a word on limitations at the end of
this video the key contribution of this
work is that instead of computing the
light transport between all possible
point pairs in the scene it uses
radiance probes that measure the nearby
illumination and tries to reconstruct
the missing information from this sparse
set of radiance probes after that we
place a bunch of receiver points around
the scene to places where we would like
to know how the indirect illumination
looks there are several things to be
taken care of in the implementation of
this idea for instance in previous works
the hierarchy of the sender and receiver
points was typically fixed in this new
work it is shown that a much sparser set
of carefully placed radiance probes is
sufficient to create high quality
reconstructions this seemingly small
difference also gives rise to a lot of
ambiguous cases that the researchers
needed to work out how to deal with for
instance possible occlusions between the
probes and receiver points need special
care the entire algorithm is explained
in a remarkably intuitive way in the
paper make sure to have a look at that
and given that we can create images by
performing much less computation with
this technique we can perform real-time
light simulations as you can see 3.9
milliseconds is a typical value for
computing an entire image which means
that this can be done with over 250
frames per second
that's not only real-time that's several
times real-time if you will
outstanding and of course now that we
know that this technique is fast the
next question is how accurate is it as
expected the outputs are always compared
to the reference footage so we can see
how accurate the proposed technique is
clearly there are differences however
probably many of us would fail to notice
that we are not looking at the reference
footage especially if we don't have
access to it which is the case in most
applications and note that normally we
would have to wait for hours for results
like this isn't this incredible there
are also tons of more comparisons in the
paper for instance it is also shown how
the density of Radiance probes relates
to the output quality and where the
possible sweet spots are for industry
practitioners is also tested against
many competing solutions not only the
results but the number and quality of
comparisons is also top-tier in this
paper
however like with all research works no
new idea comes without limitations this
method works extremely well for static
scenes where not a lot of objects move
around some movement is still fine as it
is shown in the video here but drastic
changes to the structure of the scene
like a large opening door that remains
unaccounted for by the probes will lead
to dips in the quality of the
reconstruction I think this is an
excellent direction for future research
works if you enjoyed this episode make
sure to subscribe and click the bell
icon we have some more amazing papers
coming up you don't want to miss that
thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time
[Music]
you